for you give me your top five punchline
rappers ever let's exclude you because
you're in that I I got you as top two I
told you but but who who's who's in the
five who got the best punch lines in
hip-hop history man outside of yourself
um love finesse
um Big O of course
um
Big Daddy Kane and G Rap
yo Big Daddy Kane he said that [__] on
the Big L album where he was like uh
exhibit Styles I kick With It Part of me
but I'm [__] sick with it yeah big
daddy K man for sure Big Daddy Kane is a
legend man that's like my I name dudes
that like kind of came
but for me that was my inspiration like
and I like took punch lines to the next
level like you never heard the artist
doing it like back to back like line
after line after line like before you
could I get one or two in a verse but
not you know yeah like it's everything's
kind of and um
like but for you could dissect one punch
line you already getting into another
one and making them connect like they
never really seen rappers doing that but
my inspiration is what inspired me to
want to create that style and once I
created that I don't really think nobody
took it to her a level past that yet
so that's why I gotta name the dudes
that came before me and inspired me is
there anybody from the newer generation
that you're just a fan of not even on
some punchline [__] just on some rapper
[__] like who who are you listening to
that that uh is from from I guess the
the current ERA if anybody
[Applause]
I listen all that type of [__] man I
listen to everything
um money bag yo like one of my favorite
artists are like a bunch of his um he's
fired like you know I mean I like his
voice his style and it should he be
talking about
but I like um even records like you know
I mean I'll be with my wife and with the
the women that's done with my team and
then it could be something like
come on I like that like I like
um and all that type of stuff man I'm in
all different type of bags I like all of
the new artists for different reasons
and just because they might not be
lyrical just because they might not be
this or that they might do other things
that I think is dope and I like you know
things go into 360. so I could see a lot
of artists that came before them in a
new version of the old artists that they
are so
I'm excited and I'm glad this [__]
growing is the number one form of music
in the world now period yep everybody
know what it is they know it's not a fad
that's gonna be here forever and a lot
of new artists finding different ways to
be successful in the same thing that we
call rap or hip-hop you know I mean you
don't got to be One Direction you don't
gotta just have bars or be street or be
killer it's like you could be
or even have information like you got
even Rappers that's not too smart that's
uninformed but figuring out a way to
get a fan base so it's dope